a movie starring george clooney and
space what could go wrong
we have to go we have to go go go go
gonna carry you too far okay maybe a few
things the midnight sky
netflix's latest sci-fi film based off
the book good morning midnight
is a bleak tale about love loss and what
happened to jyn er so before she joined
the rebellion
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into its twist ending
what the catastrophic event was and many
of the film's hidden easter eggs and
clues
so strap into your spacesuits boot up
some sweet caroline
and don't forget to like and subscribe
because here we
go welcome to the barbo observatory a
fictitious science facility located in
the arctic circle as we can tell from
the many jackets computer stations and
large
cafeteria this is a lab meant for a
substantial amount of scientists
the camera lingers on an odd figurine of
the egyptian god anubis the patron god
of lost souls and the helpless
and that's exactly who remains as the
last person at the observatory not
anubis meet dr augustine lofthouse a
famous astronomer and scientist spending
his last remaining days on earth
lost helpless and alone at this research
base
he meanders about getting drunk
listening to chris stapleton's tennessee
whiskey ironically
drinking whiskey what are you drinking
whiskey this is a man who has nothing to
live for in fact when the base is
evacuated due to a catastrophic event
all these scientists leave
for home while augustine opts to stay
behind
they all want to be home where is that
well for you i guess that's here the
year is 2049 and a catastrophic event
has decimated most of the world
covering it in deep plumes of radiation
the film never says
what this event was but judging by the
radiation imagery
augustine tracks on his computer and the
fact mitchell tells addie later on in
the film that humanity can quote do
better this time
it's implied that this event was
man-made and likely some sort of nuclear
war
there's even a point in which sullivan
tries to contact china
india and russia which is explicitly
forbidden so relations with these
countries
probably not the greatest in 2049 never
mentioned in the film is augustine's
ailment he suffers from a condition that
requires him to constantly transfuse his
blood
and he does so while looking up at the
midnight sky
there's something eerily poignant to the
fact he is receiving blood while staring
up
the stars where his actual blood his
daughter iris is
but that's part of the film's twist and
we'll get into that in a bit
in a flashback we meet young augustine
giving a presentation about a newly
found moon orbiting jupiter called k23
a moon due to its thermal volcanic
activity could sustain
life this will become augustine's
obsession he'll even place his work
before everything else his one a big
regret in life
he's so focused on finding life in the
stars he's forgotten the life he's had
on earth we see him develop a
relationship with a woman named gene
sullivan and as we're introduced to more
and more of his flashbacks we'll see how
his relationships shatter the more he
becomes
focused on work you want to be an
explorer augustine
to discover new worlds to give life some
hope
but while you're doing all that your own
life is just
slipping away back at barbeau augustine
tries to contact the only active space
mission
ether in greek mythology ether referred
to the upper sky
space or heaven so it's a fitting name
considering earth's upper sky
is a radioactive mess on k23 sullivan
collects water samples before finding
out her crew has left without her
this is a dream and also points at her
feelings of abandonment
as we'll find out in the film's climax
sullivan is
augustine's daughter the one he
abandoned so he could focus on his work
she doesn't even know that he's her
father making the ending doubly tragic
the crew of the aether are on their way
home after successfully completing their
two-year mission to k-23
finding that the planet can sustain life
the only problem is that they haven't
been able to contact earth for three
weeks
they've been in a blackout zone and
don't know the world has gone to [ __ ]
welcome to 2020. one of the interesting
things we learn here is that a flight
containing colonists bound for k23 was
supposed to be on its way a week ago
but they haven't heard from them either
so things on earth must have been pretty
dire if they were already planning
colonizing other planets
at barbeau augustine finds he's not
alone a young girl by the name of iris
has been left behind
earlier during the evacuation scene
we're given a red herring of a woman
unable to find her missing daughter this
was to throw us off since we'll later
find
iris is merely a figment of augustine's
imagination
young iris only speaks once throughout
the entire film
but that's during one of augustine's
dreams she's given
no voice because he doesn't even know
what she sounds like he never was around
he abandoned her
i've abandoned my child now he's forced
to live with the one person
he never wanted to live with augustine
outlines the dire nature of ether's
situation he needs to warn them of what
happened on earth so that they can go
back to k23 to essentially restart
humanity
as we'll find out a bit later iris is
pregnant with the captain of the ship's
baby we also get these moments with crew
members like mitchell and maya who
relive these hologram memories with
their families
a juxtaposition to augustine who has
none
in fact mitchell and sanchez later
decide to go back to earth using one of
the reentry pods
so that they can be with their family
who are presumably dead at this point
rather than make the journey back to k23
augustine finds a bunch of birds dying
outside the base the radiation has made
its way up
earlier than expected that combined with
the fact the antenna at barbo isn't
strong enough to reach the ether means
he and iris will have to make the
arduous trek to the lake hazen weather
station
which has a stronger antenna and should
be clear of radiation the crew of the
ether also have to make a difficult
decision they've deviated off course and
because their communications aren't
working they'll need to veer off course
in order to pick up signals from the
beacon they placed on k23
this will allow them to recalibrate
their position and get back on course
but it also puts them into unmapped
territory
augustine and iris's journey to lake
hazen is filled with moments that hint
at iris being his daughter like when he
tells her we need
sleep but switches his line to i need
sleep or when he sees her drawing a
picture of what he thinks is her mom
is that your mom i knew her face like
that once
she was as loud as you are quiet iris
silence gets at augustine
oh you should tell me something about
your life but she can't say anything
because he doesn't know anything about
her life he's never made an
effort to be there for her if you wanted
to know about you
you can introduce yourself it's only now
that he's dying and could lose her
forever that this regret
washes over him iris in this sense is a
haunting ghost reminding him
of his failures as a father a few scenes
later augustine loses iris in a blizzard
yelling out that he's here
but he's never been there for her he's
saved by a vision of gene
iris's mother which quickly turns into
that of iris as if the mother-daughter
connection wasn't evident enough
back on the ether the crew must repair
the satellite and communication
equipment
after it was wrecked by flying debris of
ice and rock while navigating the
unmapped territory
this ends in tragedy when another wave
of debris hits the ship and wounds maya
who later succumbs to her injury
and if things couldn't get any worse the
crew get their first image of earth with
swirling bands of radioactive clouds
they're able to get the communications
back up and running and augustine
confirms that humanity didn't do a good
job at looking after the place while
they were away
but he has a plan before he left for
lake hazen he downloaded calculations to
have the ether
slingshot around earth and make it back
to k23
the thing is not all the crew are on
board with this plan
mitchell receives a message from his
wife dated 10 days ago
telling him that they've been evacuated
and that his boys are sick we'll never
know if he ended up making it to her or
if she was still alive when he landed
but the important thing here is that he
chose to be with his family
even if it meant losing his life quite
the mirror to augustine who has thought
of nothing but himself
and that's part of what augustine's
journey is in this movie for the first
time in his life he is risking himself
to save a daughter he never had time for
in other words he's putting someone else
before himself in arguably the most
emotional moment of the film
augustine has a final transmission with
iris both we the viewer and augustine
know
he's her father but she does not she
tells him what an amazing man he is for
discovering such an
incredible world and that he was the
reason she joined the space program in
the first place
in his highs however he's not an amazing
man he says he's just the guy who points
and in one of his last lines to her he
says it's nice to finally meet her he
spent his whole life pushing her away
and it's kind of ironic that the closest
he's ever been with her
is when they're millions of miles apart
he asks her to describe what k23 was
like as we see him venture out into the
sunset she describes how jupiter seems
so close that you could almost touch it
as he and iris touch
at this point it's fair to assume that
augustine has passed on as we see that
young iris has disappeared
and he's alone in front of the sunset
just like he's been alone
his entire life but with this sad ending
comes hope
and uncertainty iris and adewale venture
back to k23 the only two remaining crew
members on board with iris pregnant
ready to restart humanity on a new moon
it's hard not to see the adam and eve
connection here
they hold hands for a moment before
getting back to work you'll notice that
adewale leaves iris first
exiting up the left staircase iris
continues to work for almost two minutes
before
exiting down the right staircase this
was a clear choice by director george
clooney to shoot these end credits this
way
there's something he's trying to tell us
perhaps it's that iris is doomed to meet
the same fate as her father
as she drifts further away from attawale
the camera continues to linger on the
empty room as it slowly fades to black
just like the two remaining crew members
fade into the darkness of
space we're not sure what happens to
these two but the film's main message of
love overcoming all odds
does give us hope will iris and atawali
build a new planet free from the war and
conflict that consumed it
or is humanity doomed to always drift
apart only to be born anew
i want to hear your thoughts below
thanks for watching everyone please be
sure to like subscribe and share and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much